a commemoration event is being held in
berlin today to mark five years since
the islamist terror attack on a busy
christmas market the attacker first
hijacked a truck killing the driver he
then drove it into crowds at the bright
side christmas market in central berlin
killing 11 more people another man died
a few weeks ago from injuries sustained
that night bringing the death toll to
13.
the attacker anas amri was a failed
tunisian asylum seeker who was known to
authorities a few days later he was shot
dead by police while on the run in italy
the christmas lights are on and the mood
is festive at the market in berlin's
brighcite plots
at first glance it's hard to see any
trace of the terror attack five years
ago
but market trader max miller will never
forget that day he barely escaped with
his life when a truck plowed onto the
site and destroyed his stand
i was at work and heard a loud noise it
sounded like a dumpster being rolled
away
there was a humming noise in the
background
i turned around and saw the truck and
what happened
then my wife and i ran to safety
13 people were killed in the attack and
more than 60 wounded the horror is not
forgotten
despite this max miller has opened a new
stand at the christmas market
he prefers not to show us because he
doesn't want publicity how did he find
the courage to return to the scene
i would say this is the best way of
dealing with trauma i was in therapy and
learned how to cope with my feelings
but it will be with me for the rest of
my life and when my children ask me
daddy what was it like on that day i
will probably stutter a little before i
can tell them the story
many visitors have mixed feelings about
being at the christmas market there is a
holiday atmosphere
but also a sense of grief
especially at the memorial to the
victims
[Music]
i feel a chill running down my spine i
can't put it into words
when you see the lights and smell the
hot dogs then you can forget the bad
things for a little while
it was horrible that you can't change
what happened
giving in to the terrorists was never an
option says trader max miller and his
colleagues agree
it will always be with us
you can't forget something like that
[Music]
but we all said we have to keep going
and not look back
the memory of the attack will never go
away
but today the christmas spirit has
returned to berlin's brideside plots